à marioupol le cessez-le-feu décrété par
les russes n'a pas tenu
le bataillon à d'offres évoque des
combats sanglants à l'intérieur même de
lusine où le convoi humanitaire devait
arriver
actuellement les bombardements russes et
l'aso d'azov talent ne s'arrête pas mais
les civils doivent encore être sorti
femmes enfants
beaucoup d'enfants qui sont toujours là
imaginez juste cet enfer
des accusations démenties fermement par
le kremlin
notre président et commandant suprême le
président poutine a donné l'ordre
publiquement de ne pas lancer l'assaut
sur les i nasa ce talent
aucun autre ordre n'a été donné
de son côté vladimir poutine déclaré
jeudi soir que l'armée russe était
toujours prête à assurer l'évacuation
des civils il serait encore 200 réfugiés
dans le complexe avec des combattants
ukrainiens les mettre à l'abri les
nations il a ancien leur vie
à l'heure où nous parlons qu'on voit
vite pour arriver à un obstacle ici
dévasté par deux mois de siège et de
bombardements intenses marioupol est un
symbole selon les renseignements
ukrainiens le kremlin souhaiterait y
célébrer la date anniversaire de sa
victoire face à l'allemagne nazie le 9
mai prochain